hey guys i'm riding right i'm gerry hold
on Jerry microphone anyway we're gonna
talk about fear the walking dead episode
22 here we go I liked this episode a lot
I thought it really moved this series
for it in a really cool way because a
big complaint about the first one was oh
that not enough apocalyptic stuff was
really happening or that you know I
didn't mind that but that's what a lot
of you were complaining about I feel
like a lot of people felt like they
weren't getting in the first one they're
gonna get a lot of in this second
episode like everybody like like the
curse of the walking dead is that people
complain there's end of zombie action
yeah exactly and I mean you know it's
the first episode of the show there's a
lot of setup to get through especially
on this show where we're not just
meeting people it's gonna meet everybody
before we go into this um I gotta say I
think they're a little racist against
black people in the show that's been an
issue on the walking dead before think
about it the first three defined zombies
that we really that we like new of like
people that we know that turn into
zombies I'm talking about like
characters that we gotta know beforehand
there's Cal when he becomes a zombie at
the end of the first one which was Cal
I'm so badly but the drug dealer homes
okay and then there's the principal who
looks like Barack Obama not saying that
cuz he's black he just looks like Barack
Obama they have a long thing yeah yeah
and then the third one is am at the the
the girl's boyfriend yeah yeah so
they're turning the black guys in a
zombies first racism fear The Walking
Dead turn some whites and Hispanics in
his aam beasts from friends I had who
worked in the walking dead mazes you'd
always hear people say that in the crowd
they always be like during black zombies
I was like of course yeah I mean more a
couple of you do they like their girl
zombies I'm like yeah buddy can be there
making it look like the blacks other
cause I don't know maybe they're not
going that far mom about that
controversy you are yeah I love that it
it was pretty heartbreaking when the
show started with Matt become feel like
oh he's gonna become a zombie he's got
the bike and he's got the high fever
and that's it's pretty heartbreaking
moment because this girl that has no
idea what's gonna come and the parents
are like I don't quite grasp what's
happening but we know the outcome is not
going to be good yeah you know so we got
to get you away and this show doesn't a
really interesting thing where it knows
how to tug at your heart and like just
[ __ ] break it because you know what's
coming and these guys don't yeah and I
think that works to the show's advantage
this one of the things I liked more
about these two episodes is like because
of that there is this sort of added
layer of urgency and almost bleakness it
has a very sad onset because of that
you're like oh this is not gonna head
yeah there's a rhythm to the show that I
like there's a pacing to it that it
feels more on edge and more darker more
aggressive yeah you know like The
Walking Dead don't get me wrong has
those elements but it's more of a
tension build up kind of show as opposed
to this one which is like there's
there's a race against time like they're
trying to get out of the city before all
SH [ __ ] goes down and well the walking
dead is likes because it's Georgia cuz
the country they really want you to feel
that so there's a lot more open space
and stillness and taking an obscene ur e
as is this shows in the city it's like
everything has like [ __ ] in the grounds
and the editing is quick and everything
is kind of you know claustrophobic they
take advantage of the fact of how it is
like the modern-day world I like what is
you know five years ago yag some lemon I
like how the city gets involved with
them the homeless guy gets shot in like
they can't go hey guys so there's a
[ __ ] zombie you know but they know
there is a size I had to put down the
homeless guy well yeah and and they're
at a point where where we know that
somebody that this is still small enough
that someone's gonna try and contain
that information yeah people's trust is
getting [ __ ] with and way they I don't
know but we do like so I like the
protests in the riot that was going on
in this show I'm Lorenzo as Chris I
don't feel like I we know Lorenzo real
life I don't fully know the character
yet like I don't quite get a strong
grasp like I get it he's pissed off at
his dad he's a sucky childhood divorce
and kind of doesn't know where the long
he's gotten a lot of stock scenes like
we I feel like his character could have
benefited from more scenes just to kind
of clue us in on who he is because the
way that that scene plays out or he
finds the pro
test and takes to this camera like it
almost seems like he goes from just
having a bad day to being really
involved in social rights which was just
kind of a left turn so I wish we could
have gotten yea embed like they didn't
strike me as kind of character would be
so for a protest you know but I'm sure
there's more details as to why but i
don't really wasn't spoon-fed anything
to really kind of give me a clear idea
of why he was so involved in this
protest why i was so passionate about it
but Lorenzo is a really good actor
though my favorite moment of Lorenzo was
actually when he was on the bus and wait
David bet he was trying to walk past
these kids but they weren't moving to
the lights or something and he got
annoyed by it that was a really great
meal oh just a human tick and I wish
they would let his character breathe
that whole story you know has been kind
of truncated in the midst of all the
chaos I feel like it's those moments
that you know make me want to see more
of that characters like when they're
being just human together and not
dealing with their plot so much but at
the same time it is still only second
episode you got a huge cast here you
don't have time to get to truly know
everybody yeah I just feel like we know
um what's the drug addict guy I feel
like we know like him no cliff Curtis we
know Kim Dickens and we know him and his
family yeah like the part of this that
you know the ex-wife and Lorenzo figure
into just hasn't gotten a lot of scenes
to explore yet and I'll make sure to the
scene where that goes down you know I
like the whole sequence where they're
hiding out in the barbershop there's the
riot going on outside I like I like how
that leaves it all to the imagination
it's scary you know you yeah makes the
city and the peaceful feel especially
because they were like hey I'm gonna hit
the road pick up my kid I'm gonna come
back and you're like Holly ain't coming
back man that's its [ __ ] it's [ __ ]
up right now well yeah and that's it's
nice to see the kind of early warning
signs of the bad effect like humans will
have on this apocalypse yeah and not
just the zombies cuz you already see
people kind of getting primer yeah
because you imagine a world where it was
just a zombie started happening humans
vs zombies but they're they're showing a
real primal side right yeah exactly it's
cool to explore that and I like how
they're setting up how he's with his ex
the cliff curse is with his ex-wife and
it's his son and then the Kim Dickens is
with her family and you're thinking like
okay somewhere down the road all that
we're gonna come together what kind of
conflict is are gonna create you know
having the ex around and stuff see
there's a lot of good potential for some
conflict here yeah when they all when
the whole cast comes together I feel
like it will be a really solid show ya
when i feel like it as soon as they kind
of get away from from you know the first
couple episodes of set up and they can
really breathe with their writing then I
think characters are start to come
together cuz you know the first couple
episodes it does get kind of frustrating
cuz it's like oh here's a character
exposition thing that's really yeah
convenient to have happening during the
onset of the Apocalypse yeah it starts
off like here's a bunch of Arc types but
then as you get to know them they're
more than art types yeah and I just hope
the writing can kind of meld into the to
the story more a little bit so that
those can come across more naturally
totally what I really liked to is what
they did with Kim Dickens I mean I
didn't really care for the moment where
she discovers the forgot the principle
is that whole scene like that was just
dumb over to be like little bit way I'm
gonna show the community like you've
seen enough examples to know there's no
getting through these people yeah yeah
and I'm pretty forgiving of things like
that in in horror scenarios where it's
like why would you X amount of things
but it's like you're not thinking
straight and that time I was like you've
watched somebody run over one of these
with your car like four times and it
didn't die you get it now i canna and
one might are you like well that was one
of her closest friends and she was just
in really big denial but I don't get you
the other guy I don't get the sense that
that is what was going on and it didn't
seem like that was her character choice
in the moment well that's the thing is I
want the acting and the writing to be
able to meld because they feel sort of
separate for me right now there's some
well-acted moments that feels shoehorn
cuz they gotta kind of set [ __ ] up so I
want the writing to even out but there
are some great moments with those
characters and it's it's an interesting
type of trauma to explore too because
you know it's one thing when you're like
we know what the zombie apocalypse is
always my first time I kill the zombie
I'm disturbed by it or oh I had to kill
a human during the zombie apocalypse but
it's kind of a norm for everyone I sort
of do that at that point you know and to
see where they don't know what the [ __ ]
is going on
it but she had to kill him what kind of
trauma is that gonna play into her life
I like that scene when the neighbor was
getting killed and she was blocking her
daughter from going out like that was a
powerful moment because you're seeing
like this woman's really realizing what
the [ __ ] up you know well as nice as
the show has that very personal trauma
because you do get the sense that all
these characters had lives before and as
this was happening and so in the walking
dead we kind of skipped to when this is
normal but to watch you know society
collapse like that is gonna give our
these characters a whole different set
of things to deal with absolutely
because they're not so far in they have
whole life experience is still going on
as a half societies crumbling good show
it's got potential I don't love it yet
but i but I like something I personally
love it I I personally I'm really
digging the show a lot I don't want to
compare to the walking dead kizer's you
know I brought I brought this up in my
first review for the for this show I
don't want to compare them because it's
like comparing every zombie movie you
know it's like just because it's a
zombie movie doesn't mean you have to
compare it yeah I mean it's a
geolocation is still there in the same
universe though yes that's one reason
why you can definitely compare it you
well you can compare rules basically
yeah compare how they how the rules
reflect on each other and figure out the
puzzle further that way but the shows
are shot so different and executed
totally different yeah and it seems like
they're even approaching the idea of
ensemble differently because they're all
kind of close to the same situation yeah
so yeah it does feel like they've gone
they've gone out of their way to make a
different show yeah in the same world
and I'm okay with that and I'm enjoying
it I'm not sure why all the csi's are in
the same universe and none of them
feeling anyway guys thanks for tuning in
to the channel if you're new to it you
can subscribe to the real rejects you
can check out reason to Jerry and dank
ass stubs on this channel hosted by said
jerbear
this is getting this is rather strange
so spam follow us on Facebook it's not
every got waters guys that don't do that
i know but i like being like my cats
okay all right how's the dorm that was
adorable